the case for coronavirus hysteria
collapses even further as the CDC
changes its guidelines and admits that
the virus does not spread easily if at
all through contaminated surfaces in
other words the masks and gloves are
basically useless Republican governor
Ron de santis takes a victory lap the
alarmist mayor of Atlanta makes excuses
and the MSNBC's Mika Scarborough
has an on-air meltdown then leaked to
audio services of Joe Biden discussing
with former Ukraine President Petro
poroshenko the decision to fire the
prosecutor looking into Joe's son in
exchange for a billion dollar loan
guarantee how convenient and that's just
the beginning of Joe's troubles finally
the mailbag all that more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
just when you think the experts who made
us all lock down and destroyed the
entire economy just when you think they
couldn't get more wrong it turns out
they were they were even more wrong
we'll get to that in one second but
first I've got to thank all of our
sponsors you know obviously because of
the recent fallout the economy not so
great so we really want to thank the
sponsors who's stuck with us and we want
you to support them because that
obviously helps us stay on the air so
thank you to all of them we really
appreciate it one of them in particular
is LifeLock you know there have been a
few times I hate to admit it myself
where even I have been duped by some
internet scammers you know they try to
steal a password that look it happens to
the best of us the corona virus pandemic
has sparked a massive increase in the
number of cybercrime complaints flowing
into the FBI the agency's internet Crime
Complaint Center which typically
receives 1,000 complaints per day that
was before the pandemic you know how
many they're getting now three to four
thousand almost three to four times what
they were getting before coronavirus
related schemes include domain name
spoofing personal protective equipment
vendors scams promising government
checks and fraudulent covet charities
good thing there's a life lock life lock
is a leader in identity theft protection
you know they detect a wide range of
identity threats there they're just the
best no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses life lock can see threats
that you might miss on your own if
you're just monitoring your credit join
now and save up to 25% of your first
year go to life lock calm slash Knowles
k2 wles
that's life lock calm slash Knowles for
25 percent off go there right now so I
thought that we had debunked all that
was going to be debunked about
coronavirus you know the 2.4 million
Americans are gonna die and we've all
got a lock down in perpetuity and that
where the LA is gonna look like Italy in
two weeks and right we all thought that
I thought that was that was all we were
gonna do Punk
and then yesterday CDC comes out it's
being reported by Yahoo News it's being
reported everywhere
coronavirus mainly spreads through
person-to-person contact and quote does
not spread easily uncontaminated
services do you know what that means do
you know cuz some places some headlines
they're trying to make it sound really
clinical and really scientific so that
you know what that mean that means that
the masks pretty much pointless the
glove is that people are wearing pretty
much pointless I've been saying it the
whole time I've been behaving in that
way the whole time people have said I'm
a monster I'm killing granny I'm and it
turns out we were right we were right
the whole time the skeptics were right
the scientific experts and the lab coats
who told us all to hop on one leg and
put a top hat on while singing the
national anthem and if we don't do that
we're gonna spread coronavirus the
experts who told us to do all of these
things they were wrong okay this is this
is from Yahoo News not like this is some
right-wing news source even more for Co
vid 19 officially had a name public
health officials said the virus could be
transmitted through infected respiratory
droplets and by touching infected
surfaces and then touching your nose
mouth and possibly your eyes you
remember that don't touch your face
don't you can't if you touch your face
you're gonna die of coronavirus so
people began snatching up face masks
wearing gloves and ramping up hand
hygiene to protect themselves while
touching infected services has always
been part of the messaging on how the
virus spreads the Centers for Disease
Control prevention recently shifted its
stance online CDC now says that kovat 19
spreads from person to person contact
and then lists touching infected
surfaces under a section titled the
virus does not spread easily in other
ways so back in early March CDC said it
may be possible to spread it through
these surfaces now they don't have that
spreads for person-to-person contact
don't go around kissing strangers on the
street perhaps at least be cautious when
you do otherwise you're good or if
you're not good the masks and the gloves
aren't really going to help that
according now to the CDC so I think I've
kind of lost track of the tally but I
think we're now at the point where
virtually everything
the experts told us and then the
politicians used the experts to tell us
was wrong
Florida Governor Ron de Santos was one
of the people who had a reasonable
cautious but still sceptical normal
reaction to the corona virus he did not
become hysterical he did not become an
alarmist and he was pilloried for that
they said he was going to kill people
right all the usual stuff
killing Randy especially in Florida
where a lot of older Americans live now
that he's correct now that he's been
shown correct DeSantis was speaking with
the vice president Mike Pence and he was
responding to a health official and he
laid the SmackDown our data is available
our data is transparent in fact after
Burks has talked multiple times about
how Florida has the absolute best data
so any insinuation otherwise is just
typical partisan narrative trying to be
spun and part of the reason is that
because you got a lot of people in your
profession who wax poetically for weeks
and weeks about our Florida was going to
be just like New York wait two weeks
Florida is going to be next
just like Italy wait two weeks well hell
were eight weeks away from that and it
hasn't happened not only do we have a
lower death rate while we have way lower
deaths generally we have a lower death
rate than the Acela court or DC everyone
up there we have a lower rate death rate
than the Midwest Illinois Michigan
Indiana Ohio but even in our region
Louisiana Mississippi Alabama Georgia
Florida has the lower death rate and I
was the number one landing spot from
tens of thousands of people leaving the
number one hot zone in the world to come
to my state
so we've succeeded and I think that
people just don't want to recognize it
because it challenges their narrative
yes yeah it goes on it goes on for like
20 more seconds we don't have time to
play the whole thing it's exactly right
and the fear-mongering politicians and
the fear-mongering health officials and
the fear-mongering media deserve all of
this oh how I love it what happened here
is that the Democrats made a foul Qi
bargain like a Faustian bargain a foul
chiyan bargain is where you make a deal
with the devil except that the devil is
a petite man from Brooklyn not I'm not
calling dr. pouchy the devil but the
deal that the Democrats made here is
very much like a deal with the devil if
thou Stian bargain deal with the devil
is when you sell your soul for limitless
knowledge and power and a foul chiyan
bargain is when you sell your
credibility which is your political soul
for limitless knowledge and limitless
power over the citizens and like a
Faustian bargain a foul and bargain
doesn't turn out the way that you think
it will this is this is the trouble with
deals with the devil as you get to the
end of the deal with the devil and you
realize oh no I've made a terrible
mistake I don't actually have all the
things that I wanted it's the same thing
with the foul chiyan bargain yeah the
foul chiyan bargain tells you oh good if
we if we exploit this public concern
over this virus that no one can see if
we generate mass hysteria if we make
people wear all sorts of crazy things
and lock down the economy and stay home
from work and forty million people are
gonna lose their jobs and actually more
people very likely are gonna die because
of these policies we're gonna take old
people and put them in nursing homes
because we're so incompetent in the way
that we implement this but we're gonna
get a new normal we're gonna get the
green New Deal we're gonna get all those
policies that we want we're gonna get
socialist medicine oh the things we've
wanted for a hundred years that's the
deal that they made now it's falling
apart okay you you'll live by the lab
coat you die by the lab coat if you if
you stake your entire political
credibility on the prognostications of
these soothsayer prophet scientist
experts then when those predictions turn
out not to be true
you've got nothing you've got no
credibility at all and Ron de santis
smacks you down on national television
which is a wonderful thing it never
works out the way that these guys want
it to and I'm so pleased that it doesn't
I love watching this sort of hysteria
crumble there was the mayor of Atlanta
her name is Keisha bottoms the the mayor
came out
it was a few weeks ago a few months ago
at this point I'm losing track of time
and she said when Georgia reopens
Republican governor don't forget Brian
Kemp in Georgia when Georgia reopens
deaths are gonna spike it's gonna be a
disaster
Brian Kemp is gonna have blood on his
hands and if he if it doesn't happen
that way then I am going to admit that I
was wrong well here we are all these
weeks later Georgia was I think the
first state to open certainly one of the
first and the deaths haven't spiked so
she goes on MSNBC you'll be surprised
she doesn't want to admit that she was
wrong mayor I believe I remember when we
were talking to you prior to the
quote-unquote reopening of Georgia which
as we know was very early and let's also
note there's a robust conversation going
on about the quality of the numbers
we're all getting out of the state of
Georgia but I think I remember you
saying that you hoped to be wrong that
you hoped the situation would be better
than you feared and if you were in fact
wrong you would say to the governor I
was wrong
is is there a is that a little muddier
than being able to say I was right or
are I was wrong are we as of the time of
this conversation somewhere in the
middle do you think stop stop how long
does it take you to just ask the
question hey mayor were you wrong you
said that you would say that you were
wrong and it looks like you were wrong
were you wrong were you wrong it's three
words but but Brian Williams I mean look
to his credit he at least brought up the
question but he had to preface the
question with well there is a robust
conversation about the numbers yeah the
robust conversation is people think in
many places numbers are being over
reported but he wants to insinuate that
numbers are being underreported and
there are a lot of factors at play here
and I never would want you to say that
you were wrong but do you think maybe
now here here's the answer that you
should say mayor it's too complicated
because it's in the middle and we can't
we can't say it either way so don't
don't say that you were wrong just if
you're going to ask the question ask the
question and
you're not if you just want to carry
water for these hack politicians these
alarmists then just don't bring it up
because now what happens is you look
ridiculous and even as much as you're
trying to help this mayor this mayor
mayor bottoms she she still can't get
out of it because she was dead wrong and
now she's caught in this trap so of
course finally Brian Williams stop
speaking she tries to answer the
question and she doesn't make she's
wrong um well what I can't say Brian is
it's not as bad as I thought that it
would be so I am pleased about that but
I'd still think it's too soon to say
okay so if it's not as bad as you
thought it would be then you were wrong
and then and what you said you would do
is admit that you were wrong admit that
you were wrong okay that's like I feel
like I'm Ron de santis talking to that
healthcare it just didn't meet you were
wrong okay
or don't I don't even care because
people are realizing it day by day by
day and the longer that the left and the
Democrats cling to this hysteria the
more ridiculous they're going to look
and and the more they double down on
this premise on the foul Sheehan bargain
that we don't we don't design our own
politics we actually just outsource it
all to the lab coats okay then what do
we need you for what's the point you
know there are two political visions at
play here there's well I don't even I
couldn't even call them both
authentically political there's the one
political vision which conservatives
have which is hey politics is
complicated society is complicated there
are eternal questions that don't have
precise scientific answers and we have
to debate those things and that's why we
have self-government and we need to
balance factors like making sure that we
can protect public health while
preserving our liberties and preserving
the rule of law and not allowing the law
enforcement to get too aggressive and
keeping the economy going because a down
economy kills people just as much as a
virus actually more right so there are
all these factors and we just have to
debate what our priorities are that's
politics then there's the kind of
leftist shortcut that they tried to take
which is
politics is a an exact science we we
know exactly what we should do it's not
like we have to debate these questions
we just know exactly what the scientific
answer to politics is and we're gonna
let some guy in a lab coat decide it all
for us because conveniently right now he
agrees with the things that we want well
okay what happens what happens when that
guy's power falls apart sadly this mayor
of Atlanta has probably got the most
coherent response of any of these
lefties to their narrative falling apart
we tune in on MSNBC to Mika Brzezinski
joe scarborough's wife and co-host who
didn't really have any argument to make
other than throwing a temper tantrum at
Donald Trump and saying that she was
going to call Twitter to get his account
kicked off and your lack of ability to
handle this massive human catastrophe
the fact that you've made it worse and
that you make it worse every day and
that you won't even wear a mask to
protect people from your germs but the
germs you're spreading on Twitter first
of all Twitter you shouldn't be allowing
this and you should be taking these
tweets down and you should be ashamed of
yourself you'll be hearing from me on
this because this is BS but Donald
you're a sick person you're really a
cruel sick disgusting person so as you
know Mika will not be changing her last
name from Brazil ski to Scarborough but
she will be changing her first name to
Karen if you've seen this we mentioned
it on the show the other day there's
this meme that's going around about
Karen which is a sort of busybody lady
who's telling everybody their business
and you know asks to speak to the
manager and just you know everything's a
big fight and very involved in what
everybody else is doing that would seem
to be what Mika is doing here it's like
the par excellence example of this I'm
gonna get you kicked off I'm gonna
you're gonna hear from me Twitter I'm
you're gonna what I'm hearing from you
now because you're speaking on
television you're gonna hear from me I'm
gonna call your manager and I'm gonna
get Donald Trump kicked off Twitter
because he's a meanie and I don't like
him and he was right about everything
and we were wrong we were totally wrong
not a great look
not a great look obviously they don't
have any kind of argument to this they
blew it
not just mika brzezinski on all the way
over in washington DC Nancy Pelosi was
asked about Trump asked about her
comments on Trump you know the the last
best argument she had against him is she
called him fat that was like the best
thing she could muster now she's saying
that he has excrement on his shoe you're
asking me about the appropriateness of
the actions of this President of the
United States so completely
inappropriate in so many ways that it's
almost a given it's like a child who
comes in with mud on their pants or
something that's the way it is they're
outside playing that's what it he comes
in with doggy Doo on his shoes and
everybody who works with him has that on
their shoes too for a very long time to
come so I don't know I hear doctors
talked to me about saying you know
what's matter with him things he says
are so inappropriate for a President of
the United States the comments he makes
about women comments he makes about
women so inappropriate so interpret the
things he says are so inappropriate for
a president there so unbefitting a
holder of high office also his shoes are
covered in doggy Doo mmm what you see
how it kind of sounds like you're doing
the thing that you're accusing him of
doing the things that Donald Trump says
about women well I don't listen to
things you say about men well I I
understand Donald Trump is it made some
mean comments including a bat care and
Brzezinski but think about the things
you say about him you went on TV and
called him fat and then beyond that
beyond this stupid like you used a a
mean term and then I used a mean term
how about the allegations against Joe
Biden remember Joe Biden your candidate
for president he's being I guess
somewhat credibly accused I don't know
who knows if the allegations are
credible or not Democrats have ignored
it completely he's being accused by a
former staffer of doing a very specific
and there is some corroboration of that
okay Donald try oh no they always say
there are seven million women accusing
Donald Trump of rape well how come we
haven't heard about any of them don't
you think if any of those allegations
were serious that then the news would
would put them on television 24/7 all
the time of course because there none of
them come even close to the allegation
against Joe Biden the way he talks about
women what about one of the what about
your side Nancy what about the things
that you're doing there's a whole lot of
projection
she's got nothing there is a lot of dirt
though in terms of moving past the
coronavirus for a little bit there's a
lot of serious news that is not being
covered by Joe Biden because Joe Biden
got caught in leaked audio talking about
that crooked deal with the leader of
Ukraine we'll get to that one second
first though I've got to thank our
friends over at ring you know these days
especially all the time but these days
especially it's important to know who's
at your door we're home more than usual
these days but it's still hard to keep a
close eye on things more deliveries mean
more boxes left unattended and more
opportunities for packages to go missing
a lot can happen outside our front doors
and we are not always free to check on
things in person with ring you can keep
your home safe no matter where you are
ring is on a mission to make
neighborhoods safer their home security
products are designed to give you peace
of mind around the clock from video
doorbells and security cameras to smart
security lighting and alarm systems ring
has everything you need to make sure
your family and belongings are safe and
secure you know you know I told you I
give ring to some of my friends as a
housewarming gift friend of mine came in
yesterday apparently his laptop got
stolen out of his apartment in the
middle of the night because he didn't
have ring all right night Jennifer
obviously what's the first thing I'm
gonna tell him you got to get ring get a
special offer I'm the ring welcome kit
when you go to ring calm / Knolls the
welcome kit includes the ring video
doorbell 3 and shine pro it's all you
need to start building custom security
for your home today go to ring comm /
Noles
that's ring comm / Knolls forget for a
moment the top-line news story the news
story that everyone's talking about
which is this debate over the corona
virus forget for a
and all the mud that Democrats are
trying to sling on Trump let's just go
down and remember that there's a
presidential race going on it is 2020
Joe Biden is the presumptive Democratic
nominee he's being accused not just of
the sexual allegations but of some
pretty serious corruption involving his
son and the Obama administration and
Ukraine right obviously no one's
covering that now we've got leaked audio
from Joe Biden speaking to then-vice
prey then ukrainian President Petro
poroshenko about this crooked deal where
Joe Biden said you've got a fire the
prosecutor Victor shoke and looking into
my son and I will give you a 1 billion
dollar loan guarantee from the United
States here's the tape mr. President Joe
Biden how are you thank you well you are
doing very well congratulations I'm
getting a new prosecutor general I know
there's a lot more than that to be done
but I really I really think that's I
think that's good and I understand
you're working with a-rod in the coming
days on a number of additional laws to
secure the IMF so but congratulations on
installing the new prosecutor general
it's going to be critical for him to
work quickly to repair the damage
choking did and I'm a man of my word I
am and that now that the new prosecutor
generals in place we're ready to move
forward and signing that new 1 billion
dollar loan guarantee Wow when I heard
this for the first time I thought it was
fake I assumed it was some Biden
impersonator and some Ukrainian
impersonator and they had because you
couldn't have scripted this any better
hi there poroshenko this is Joe Biden
the vice president thanks for firing
that guy that was looking into my son
now I'll give you a billion dollars it's
almost exactly what he said and I
thought there's no way that any sitting
politician would be this careless to
speak this freely about something that's
really stinks of corruption and then I
remembered oh it is
Biden oh I know wait a minute if anybody
is gonna talk about this freely and
imprudently it would be Joe Biden
so that's Joe Biden's side of it then
later in the tape Petro poroshenko
reiterates the very deal that Joe Biden
mentioned second thing is that I want to
thank you that you give me your word
that immediately when we change
realization and I appoint the new
prosecutor general and it would be you
little term as we agreed on our previous
meeting in Washington and when it
happened we can have at least longer
okay and thank you why is Joe Biden so
interested in this prosecutor general in
Ukraine why what what Joe Biden would
say is it's because the previous
prosecutor general was corrupt and so we
didn't want to support Ukraine because
there was generalized corruption who
cares I mean we're talking about these
billion-dollar loan guarantees during a
war war time right Ukraine versus Russia
why do you care about generalized
Ukrainian corruption also if you're
worried about the corruption you're
talking to the main guy Petro poroshenko
so the only corruption you got to be
worried about is that guy right if
you're worried that the money is gonna
be frittered away or something it's the
story just doesn't add up
clearly Biden had a personal vendetta
against this this prosecutor general
Viktor shokhin and he talks about it and
then poroshenko reiterates he says yeah
what you know as you asked me to do when
I was in Washington we are gonna ditch
that guy and put in this other guy so
thank you for the billion dollars stinks
to high heaven no one's covering him if
you play a few places have have affirmed
that this is a real tape but they're
only talking about the story as though
the story were the fact that it leaked
no no the real story is what is in those
tapes this thing has seemed extremely
corrupt from the beginning and that only
seems clearer now that's only the
beginning of Joe Biden's troubles
because nobody is taking Joe Biden
seriously a lot of people are talking
about the vice presidential candidate as
the person who really matters here
because Joe seems like he's in a pretty
steep decline so
there are a number of people vying for
the vice presidential nod one worse than
the next we'll get to the the main one
in a second you know the one everyone's
talking about but another person who is
apparently being vetted for vice
president is maybe the the least popular
governor in America during the score ona
virus Gretchen Whitmer in Michigan
here's Gretchen Whitmer bragging about
being vetted for Vice President on NBC
how's the vetting process going so far
you being vetted by mr. Biden you know
I've had a conversation with some folks
but the fact of the matter is all of my
energy is going into helping my state
through this crisis unlike one that
we've been in a hundred years in this
country we have to get it right and I
was elected to be the governor of the
state of Michigan it is the honor of a
lifetime
and that's where I'm spending a hundred
percent of my energy and focus this
conversation that you had how would you
how would you characterize the
conversation it was just an opening
conversation and it's not something that
I would call a professional you know
formalized vetting I am making a little
bit of time to stay connected to the
campaign but you know the most important
thing that I have to do right now is be
the governor of the my home state that's
all that matters to me in this moment
that's where I'm gonna stay all my
energy focused all that matters to me in
this moment is being the governor of my
state and that's why I'm going on
national network television to talk
about how maybe I'll be the vice
president but I don't really want to
talk about that I know I know that I've
been talking about it a lot did I
mention by the way that I might be the
vice president
yeah Joe Biden called me we had a chat
but really I'm not interested in that I
just want to talk about being governor
okay I I don't know whether Whitmer is
being vetted or not I mean in a way I
guess it makes sense because winning
Michigan would really help the Democrats
out in a way it makes sense because Joe
Biden has pretty dumb political
instincts these days at least at the
presidential level he's been very good
at remaining a senator and in national
life for 50 years but he's never had any
talent at really going up to the next
level and so this would be that this
would be part and parcel of that the
other possibility here is that she's not
being really seriously vetted at all by
the Biden campaign that maybe the Biden
campaign is trying to keep her happy
but really regardless Gretchen Whitmer
is talking about this on television as a
shot across the bow at Stacey Abrams
his Stacey Abrams has really changed the
game here Stacey Abrams is this failed
gubernatorial candidate she lost then
she wouldn't concede then she keeps
pretending that she didn't lose and now
she's campaigning actively openly for
vice president really it's really ugly
it's an ugly thing to do doesn't look
good I mean but the the media are really
enthusiastic about her for a number of
reasons and so now the other people have
to campaign as well including people
like Gretchen Whitmer so I wouldn't be
surprised at all if the Biden campaign
has never picked up the phone talk to
her she wants to take the shot across
the bow to say hey wait a second this
isn't just Stacey Abrams running for
vice president I am running for vice
president too and she's not getting
anywhere near the coverage that Stacey
Abrams is I've wanted to get to this
article all week this is an article from
The Washington Post
I think it's like 60 pages long it's a
profile of Stacey Abrams that is I'm not
joke I think it's like it's a it's
novel-length
profile it Ben Washington boast of this
failed governor candidate and what
Stacey Abrams well she's ever been as a
state Rep and yet she's being talked of
as one of the most important politicians
in America just a few lines to give you
the sense of this fiction just a few
lines to give you a sense of this
propaganda the power of Stacey Abrams
despite losing the Georgia governor's
race in 2018 she has moved quickly to
political prominence right because you
you gave her political prominence she
hasn't moved quickly to it you've just
given it to her because you wanted to
pretend that she won the race anyway
will she be the vice presidential pick
for Democrats I don't know you you guys
are doing this so or is she I should ask
you Washington Post you're the ones who
are gonna pick this kind of thing first
line there's a big buzz at the
Loudermilk Convention Center in downtown
Atlanta at a gathering called paradigm
shift 2.0
when she Stacey Abrams is finally
introduced the women shout and leaped to
their feet young women stand on chairs
camera phones flash abrams who appears
both amused and slightly disturbed by
the fuss over yeah I bet she's real
disturbed Stacey Abrams hates the
limelight yeah there's one thing I know
that Stacey Abrams she hates getting
attention right it's a woman who refuses
to admit that she lost the race goes on
television all the time pretends to be
the governor of Georgia yeah no she's
disturbed by the fuss over she takes
control of the chaotic scene takes
control she's a leader I've witnessed
this level of affection for very few
political leaders in the Democratic
circles I've been in since the 1980s
yeah no you've witnessed this level of
affection for whichever one you guys are
elevating in any given moment sure I
guess you can only really elevate one at
a time but you've got you picket you are
the circles you are the affection and
then this is this is the best life
pandemonium ensues as she walks to the
far left of the stage like a runway
supermodel I'm not gonna make any
comment about that I'm I'm just reading
The Washington Post don't you can't
trick me into making a comment about
that I'm just see the words say it's
right there she walks across the stage
like a runway supermodel stops on a dime
poses tilts her head slightly and smiles
camera flashes explode
she pivots she next pivots and walks
slowly to the center of the stage
freezes there and repeats the pose again
the flashes explode they explode there
they don't explode and cameras haven't
worked that way in a hundred years the
image that she's giving you is like it's
some old timey press conference and the
guys holding up the flash and he's got
the camera they click it in their light
bulb and the camera explodes that none
of that happened none none of what is
being described here happened except in
the imagination the fevered imagination
of the partisan operatives who pretend
to be journalists at places like the
Washington Post
that's
in fiction that's living in fantasy
that's living in delusion and it's
something that Democrats do regularly
the trouble with that it ties right back
in to what we were talking about with
the coronavirus with the foul chiyan
bargain the trouble with that with
staking all of your credibility on this
fantasy rather than just like calling it
like you see it having a little bit of
skepticism looking at the facts and
interpreting them as accurately as you
can trouble with just pushing this
fantasy as if by merely saying certain
things you can change reality this has
been the left's pitch going all the way
back to intellectuals like Karl Marx
right if you just change the words you
will change the reality if I call a boy
a girl then the boy really is a girl if
I say that the disease is the virus is
going to kill everybody it's gonna kill
three million people then it really will
if I say that the virus spreads in a
certain that really will if I say that
this failed gubernatorial candidate is a
runway supermodel the most important
politician and the last twenty years in
American history then that really will
be the case but it won't be but it won't
be because reality reasserts itself in
the end and that is our wonderful
conservative consolation when we
consider all those shady deals pouchy
and bargains that the left makes all
right we got to get to the mailbag first
though join us for a backstage Memorial
Day special May 27th at 7 p.m. Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific you you know a little while
ago we did this double double tumbler
promo so if you signed up for the daily
where you got two left two steers
tumblers it was extremely popular
because it's it's double as good right
so we're bringing that back but there's
a catch here's the catch the double
tumbler do I have my second one I do
good I need it I need it today for the
Washington Post we got these two
tumblers right but it's only available
for our most exclusive membership tier
all access the all access membership
tier is our premier level of membership
you get you get everything you get the
Q&A is you get exclusive editorial
articles from then you get about two
bonus hours of his show you get an ad
free web
experience head on over to daily
wire.com slash subscribe to join all
access and yet 15% off with coupon code
Knowles Cana wles
so you're getting two tumblers and 15%
off right now with coupon code Knowles
can or wles at daily wire.com slash
subscribe head on over there we'll be
right back with Mel back
from Kevin hey Michael I recently got
into an argument with a leftist on
social media about socialism he said
America is a socialist country because
we have a publicly funded police force
fire departments public schools and
roads what would you say to rebut that
thanks came for been stayed for Knowles
a great question you hear this one a lot
they say that if the government has any
sort of public service then that is
socialism but that's obviously
preposterous on its face how do we know
that because socialism as an ideology is
not very old couple hundred years old
right no more than that now I guess two
to three hundred years old and yet
societies had public services more than
two or three hundred years ago actually
they've always had public services and
the government has provided certain
things for the people so it it just by
definition all of those things can't be
socialism because socialism is very
recent and young and that phenomenon is
very old and has a long-standing when we
talk about things like the military or
the police or the fire department these
are services that the government in many
ways is instituted to establish right to
protect us from threats abroad and to
maintain law and order here in the
United States we've had them since
certainly since the very beginning of
our country and every civilization in
history the world has had that as well
socialism is a little bit different
socialism takes a very specific ideology
developed by people such as Karl Marx it
used the world as a class struggle
between the proletarians and the
bourgeoisie it says that the workers of
the world need to unite the workers need
to come together seize the means of
production the way that this would be
affected in reality is that the
government would nationalize whole
industries in which you see a lot of big
push right now on the left which is more
and more each day
openly socialist to do and that this
will create a sort of utopia on earth
the difference between socialism and
communism I know those those terms get a
little bit confused sometimes
it's a little bit of a distinction
without a difference so - to a good
analogy would be this Christians go to
heaven and socialists go to communism so
in other words there is this utopian
idea which for Christians would be
heaven so utopian place it's like
paradise it's perfection
and for socialists it's actually utopian
meaning no place because they try to
make a heaven on earth which is
communism and you never get there which
is why all of these socialist
experiments always end up in tyranny and
they somehow never get to that wonderful
blissful place that they always promised
very different subjects obviously I
think part of the reason this gets
confused is because in the United States
we have distilled conservative thought
down to this very shallow narrow
ideology where anytime the government
does anything we say that it's socialism
but that's not true that's never been
true in this country that's a very
reductionist kind of hyper or SuperDuper
libertarian view of government and it's
just not very helpful to think about so
I think we've got to broaden our scope a
little back a little bit look both more
deeply philosophically and more broadly
historically and you can see that not
every time the government does anything
is it socialism but what the left is
pushing now very much is from that dear
austere religious podcaster and Lord of
CO FFA what are your thoughts on the
Benedict option as outlined by Rod
Dreher and to a lesser extent pope
benedict xvi
is it a viable option for christians in
the u.s. as the culture continues to
decline and becomes more hostile to
Christianity and Christian values if not
how do you think the church should
proceed into the future given the
immense challenges from the culture love
the show keep up the good work
broadly speaking Benedict option is this
idea that Christians need to go live in
the woods more or less and you know
follow things like the rule of Saint
Benedict is as Empire collapses then you
can go and form these sort of
monasteries and be a part of the world
and
serve the faith and preserve our culture
for when we get to a more civilized time
because we are rapidly descending into
darkness I mean I think there's a place
for that
but I don't think we're quite there yet
and you know all of the proponents of
the Benedict option I notice are still
going on television and still writing
things and there's you know I just don't
think we're at this point yet where we
are all living in in the woods and you
know we're kind of fully really removed
ourselves from society but at a certain
point that very likely will happen and
that's an important thing because you
need to keep the flame of the faith and
the flame of civilization going even
during those periods of persecution and
darkness and we are descending gradually
into a period of persecution we've gone
from what you would call a Christian
culture into now a secular materialist
culture with all sorts of kooky
superstitions and ideologies and false
religions such as socialism or
environmentalism or or spiritualism you
know kind of the religion of the self
all of these things are transgenderism
which is Gnostic dualism all of these
things are cropping up now and becoming
increasingly hostile to Christianity so
be on the lookout for that be willing
and ready to do that if you have to but
in the meantime I think there's still a
little chance that we can convince our
fellow citizens not to not to hasten the
descent from Kathryn hi Michael you said
you can make me scream but you can't
make me sing the other day on your show
want to clarify didn't say that to you
oh well that's not something I said to
you but I was saying that broadly is
that a quote from somewhere or did you
turn this particular phrase Google has
availed me nothing
it's a delightfully macabre and visceral
idea and I would like to properly
attribute it what I use in the future
thank you so much it's not my own like
so many great phrases that I have
parroted I cribbed it I took it this
this exchange
I heard from my good friend and priest
Father Rutter one of the great
wordsmiths around whose rade writing you
should read and whose homilies you
should listen to and I heard this thing
I just heard this in in his church one
time he mentioned now I forget the name
of the opera singer and I forget the
name of the Nazi official
but it's the story of during the rise of
Nazism in Germany an official wants to
hear this this opera singer sing and she
refuses to go on stage and goes
backstage and says go out there and
perform we can make you sing and she
says you can make me scream but you
can't make me sing I don't think the
story is apocryphal I think it did
happen as I recall hazily the details
though I'll have to look it up and try
to find find the specifics on it
even if it were apocryphally it gets to
a real truth about that culture and and
our culture as well increasingly you're
seeing the left try to coerce us into
untruths and into pretty dark things and
they're saying will ruin your career if
you don't spout lies will I mean it for
just a very simple one if you don't say
that little boys should be injected full
of hormones and chemicals to look more
like little girls even though it will
fundamentally distort and destroy their
biology if you don't say that now you
could lose your job you could be kicked
out of school you could be called a
hater and a bigot and ostracized from
society and what the left is telling us
is we can make you sing well make you
sing tune that we want you to sing and
what we need to say to all of them is
well you can make me scream but you
can't make me sing from Joel partisan
traditionalist Knowles I seem to have
noticed that you seem to be strongly
against the prospect of a Libertarian
Party presidential candidate need I
remind you that Abraham Lincoln was a
third party candidate of the Republican
Party do you see a possibility of an
electorate significantly disgusted with
the Democratic Party that it would fall
to third place and be thrown into the
wastebasket of history along with the
Whig party I would be open to fully
kicking those donkeys off the national
stage for the sake of the Constitution
preservation of the Republic thank you
for reading my query and partial rant I
am interested in your question because
usually when you hear is there going to
be a third party it's people who are
disenchanted with their own parties you
say I don't like the Republican Party
but I'm still obviously not a Democrat
so can i you know do you think there's
gonna be a third party like a
libertarian or something but what you're
saying is I am a Republican I don't like
the Democrats and I want there to be a
third party just to destroy the
Democrats I wish that would happen but I
don't think it's going to I don't see
any evidence that's going to Democrats
are still a pretty sturdy party they're
still fairly coherent the the only split
that you would get is between the more
old-school moderate wing and the woke
progressive wing but that old-school
model at moderate wing doesn't really
believe in anything so you know they'll
kind of blow me you think of guys like
Bill Clinton or Joe Biden it's not that
they're moderate by conviction it's that
they're moderate by circumstance and by
convenience you know if the winds blow
in the other direction they could become
very woke so I don't I don't see the
moderates so-called putting up any sort
of fight and I think that the woke
people have more or less taken over the
party I think when Tom Perez the head of
the DNC said that AOC is the future of
the Democratic Party he's probably right
and so if the party does collapse which
would be nice if it did at some point I
don't think it's going to happen for
some time by the way I do have to thank
somebody in the mailbag I forget who it
was we may have and we may have lost so
here it is from Becky I have to thank
Becky speaking of me cribbing people's
slogans because I saw Becky's question
the phrase foul Chee and bargain we
don't have we don't have a chance to
answer all of her questions maybe we'll
try to get to it next time in the
mailbag but I do want to thank her for
that because I think that phrase totally
encapsulates an idea that a lot of us
are thinking about that Democrats made a
short-term deal to you know really exert
a lot of power over all of us and it's
in the long run falling apart as all
deals with the devil do and we can all
laugh well well that that political
calculation while that hysteria and
while that alarmism falls apart a silver
lining in a storm cloud that's our show
I'm Michael Knowles as the my gonna show
I'll see on Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you